and it'll be the 14th start for gobber
remember when he had command issues the
first uh you know couple of outings he's
walked four spilling his last eight
this is a bullet to mcmahon and he hangs
in there and makes a nice play
comes a very easy out in between hop on
the dirt he takes the drop step
trust his hands trust his glove he keeps
the glove down
works his way up comber appreciates it
101 plus miles an hour off the bat
of tommy pham here's trent grisham
and another chance for mcmahon this
little easier two outs
three straight oh and two counts too
on the outside corner and that's uh
popped up to right field
near the line charlie's got it and
that's a very nice beginning for austin
gomper
on the hill for the padres is to nelson
lameet 28 year old making his seventh
start
one down here for jonathan dazza 2-2
count here to dazza
and that is strike three frozen two down
first strikeout for danelle schindlerman
that fastball in that i was talking
about just set up that slider away
two down blackman at first and it brings
up trevor story
ground ball left side oh that was close
then he gets it and fires to first and
the side is retired
tatissa machado kind of came together
there but manny able to make the play
fernando tatis junior is going to lead
it off
and it's on the ground to trevor and
he'll throw out his counterpart
one out hosmer at 258 on the year
strike attic by gomber oh hosmer that's
his first and they're two gone
this is the change-up for gomber he's
not afraid to use it
and for good reason two on for trevor
story
2-1 this is up the middle jason
he'll come home one nothing colorado you
gotta love two out rallies
and that has to feel especially good for
trevor
just his second hit since coming off the
injured list
that's career rigby 399.
so here's grisham with krone holding fam
on
back at gomper good feed to second on
the third trev had to put a little more
pepper on that one
it's good to see it's a good sign for
trevor
it's a great play by gomber
leave your feet but he makes a good saw
throw to second that's the most
important get that lead
out and trevor quick exchange
long body of cj crone at first one out
one on
and here is elias diaz 2-2
is on the ground headed to shortstop
could be two to second for one
on the first it is two nicely done the
double play
here's fernando to tease junior against
austin gomber in the fifth
another 2-2 from gomper curveball see
later
that is strikeout number three tonight
for austin
tuttis is arguing with endings about
asking first base umpire to at least
look at the swing
he did not indicate on the swing that
was a strike
two down here in the fifth inning will
myers
hit sharply into right field a base hit
for myers taking it the other way
a two out single ends up jay cronenworth
and this is up the middle trevor's there
he's got to go to first and hustle
and he does in time the padres go into
their pen here
into the bottom of the fifth inning
after 75 pitchers from the nelson lumet
here is ryan
got an weathers hitting streak on cue he
smokes that up the middle
[Applause]
there goes tapia
i thought he had a hand and rymel
thought he had a hand in
and rymel's not leaving second base stop
signs up
this will tell us everything we need to
know he's safe
he is safe it will be the sixth stolen
base
for rybell one to nothing the rockies
have the lead over the padres as we head
into the sixth inning
fly ball to left field deep and tapia
going back so is dazza
and it is up off the wall and it comes
back
to the second is carratini and he's got
a double to begin things here in the
sixth inning
off the yellow right yep came back in
and it comes back yep and that fan did
not
interfere in any way gomber ready
ground ball to first crown's got it
well done austin gomber gives up a
leadoff double
and the padres don't score
the third machado spins and fires and
it's in time
nice play by manny machado makes it look
so easy
ho-hum for manny machado at third base
plays it back on the big hop spin glove
side
flip it over to hosmer and he makes it
look so
easy see if he goes with the breaking
ball right here
mcmahon strikes out that is the first
strikeout for ryan weathers
two down in the sixth inning and that'll
bring up to junior here's the one two
he got it got
so you have all the pitches to contend
with
and you're just stuck trying to figure
out what in the world is he going to
throw
it's another rosin back cj crone against
ryan weather ball
deep right he doesn't see him
no idea doesn't matter he's gone
two nothing colorado will deep to
everybody including himself
cj with his sixth home run he's been a
bit of a slow
that was great to see and timely
it's a great bat he's spinning around a
fastball 160
miles an hour and pulling 13 ground ball
outs tonight well it just so happens he
happens to have a change up that's a
pretty good ground ball weapon
and another ground ball make it 14
trevor
replaces his feet and how easy was that
now
ryan mcmahon he has struck out three
times tonight
center field third
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fly ball to right field and deep
blackman going back at the wall
that's gone two-run home run for trent
christian brings the padres back within
a run
well wouldn't you know it padres in town
it'll come down to an encounter in a
one-run game between the rockies closer
daniel bard
and the young sensation fernando tatis
jr
popped off playable
hampson calling for it he's got it
iraqis win it three to two
austin gomper eight marvelous innings
as the rockies come home and continue to
play good baseball at 20th and blake
they're now 21-14 at home